bien alors maintenant on va baisser la
lumière et on va se la faire
bouge on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
interview dernier coup Geneviève de
Fontenay
Geneviève dernier coup dur
er
non dernier coup dur précieusement au
dernier coup dur votre dernier coup dur
moi mon dernier coup ça va très bien
voilà Geneviève n'a pas de coup dur
dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de cœur
nous avons apporté un peu de joie à des
enfants trisomiques qui regardent des
Miss France avec beaucoup de d'émotions
il y en a plein contrairement
pas du tout
dernier coup de foudre c'est vous mon
cher
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup de gueule
ce soir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu